the Manu National Park is located in
southeastern Peru in the Amazon basin
much of the park is rainforest Rob
Williams of the Zoological Society of
Frankfurt Germany wants to help preserve
this ecosystem he heads a project that
is partially funded by the German
Environment ministries international
climate initiative a dozen species of
reptiles live here Caymans can grow up
to six meters in length countless
species of mammals and birds also live
in menu the extensive dense forest has
not been fully explored it no doubt
still holds many secrets people also
live in the National Park indigenous
groups such as the matcha Ginga Rob
Williams and his team visit them
regularly today they're talking to the
children about how important it is to
take care of the world they live in the
Amazon ecosystem the challenge for these
communities and we're just really trying
to help them out find their way in this
is to see what they can do so they can
maintain the traditional way of living
for those who want to live that way and
those who want to earn money live in the
monetary economy outside the park can
also have a foot in that world and and
that's the challenge for each individual
and for the community as a whole many
families have cleared small plots in the
forest to grow crops such as cassava
most of the matcha gangga are hunters
fishermen and gatherers
fish and forest animals are important
sources of protein only the men go
hunting with bow and arrow like their
fathers and grandfathers before them it
would be easier with guns but the park
administration persuaded the hunters to
do without firearms so they wouldn't
kill too many animals too quickly today
these men find and kill a woolly monkey
the machi kanga and the park
administration have made a deal
they help preserve the ecosystem in
return for certain benefits the hunters
keep a list of the animals they beg
basically the idea is that communities
can really have information about how
much they're hunting and what the state
of the populations are out in the areas
they're hunting are and then hopefully
they can think about taking some
decisions towards management of that
resource to ensure that it's there
forever the much again go demonstrate
that it is possible for humans to
actively contribute to the maintenance
of their ecosystem and its biodiversity